[Musica]
[Applauso]
avete sentito granny è tornato nello
specifico gremi natale decorate di
grendi natale dall'anno scorso aveva
nascosto i regali di natale questa volta
ha nascosto i calendari dell'avvento in
questa sala
quindi dovremo trovare tutti i calendari
dell'avvento senza essere presi dal
granny avremo quattro giorni di tempo
quindi quattro turni che questo video
raggiunge i 20 mila mi piace syrah anche
il video in cui in cui credi natale
nasconde i regali di natale di lasciate
un bel mi piace se non mi seguite ancora
su instagram andati a seguirmi il nome
anita stories
se volete seguitemi anche su tik tok e
ora iniziamo subito la ricerca del primo
calendario
vediamo se c'è qualcosa in camera come
gli azzurri di natale credere dovrò
venderlo sopra sto per me to the mary
dov'è andata
va beh io non vedo più nessuno allora ne
approfitto per prendere il calendario
dell'avvento da sopra l'armadio non
pensa però di riuscire a prenderlo ci
arrivo
devo prendere una scala o una sedia
stavo a prendere calendario
sì ce l'ho fatta ragazzi ho preso il
primo calendario e il calendario
dell'avvento dei pokémon
ora possiamo andare a fare l'unboxing sa
perché gremi non sia nascosta qui
[Musica]
se venissero il corridoio borse
l'abbiamo fatta siamo riusciti a
prendere il primo calendario senza
essere preferivo calendario il
calendario dell'avvento dei pokémon che
bello vediamo subito cosa troviamo
dentro prima casellina che carino e il
primo pokémon trovato e in onda
casellina secondo pokemon e leo ma o non
mirko ormai come si pronuncia comunque
il pokémon del team rock per la
casellina qua abbiamo un pezzo
dell'albero di natale che dobbiamo
costruire dopo e dell albero di natale
dei pokémon numero 4 marine o questo è
uno dei pokémon nuovi che non mi ricordo
il nome perché o no erlino berlino sta
arrivando a sabotare tutto lo vedete
berlino vuole mangiare tutti i pokémon
fermo berlino dopo che vi faccio vedere
dai un po di pazienza resto è una dei
nuovi pokémon
non mi ricordo come si chiama scrivetelo
nei commenti e uno degli starter d'acqua
numero 5 abbiamo il resto dell'albero di
natale dopo andiamo a montarlo numero 6
cuban forse cuban se non sbaglio proprio
chi un bond guardate che carino numero
sarebbe chi è bello e grow olet
io adoro i pokémon di tipo fuoco
bellissimo numero 8 abbiamo ancora un
pezzo dell'albero di natale che andiamo
a montare dopo numero 9 resto è bull
peak però è la versione non so se
versione shiny di questa inversione
shiny o che versione è comunque volpi
bianco e celeste
l'uomo e ragazzi pacchi regalo da
mettere nell'albero di natale numero 11
il vento questo è uno dei miei pokémon
preferiti ed è detto guardate sembra uno
slice rosa un prophete live è troppo
bello è detto e lui si può trasformare
in qualsiasi pokémon numero 12 ecco qua
questo è lo stesso un pokémon delle
nuove generazioni mi sembra che si
chiami prime e prime on
non mi ricordo scrivete voi miei
commenti numero 13 altri pacchetti
regalo da mettere sotto l'albero 14
anche questo pokémon non mi ricordo mai
come si chiama sembra appunto pikachu ma
ha un nome diverso e particolare c'è una
storia particolare dietro questo pokémon
se la conoscete
scrivete l'ha pure nei commenti che
carino numero e quindi abbiamo
quest'altro pokémon che scusate anche
questo non mi ricordo come si chiama
perché io mi ricordo tutti quelli della
prima e seconda generazione ma gli altri
non mi ricordo mai i nomi con questo
milian ponce norlight scrivete pure il
nome nei commenti numero 16 altri
pacchetti regalo quest'altro pokémon
super carino che fa sempre parte di una
delle ultime generazioni e quindi io mi
ricordo il nome ma forse si è scritto
qui no qui che carino numero 18 abbiamo
zilli pop con il microfono troppo carino
numero 19 le slitte per l'albero numero
20 abbiamo bulbo saur guardate che
carino 21 abbiamo scoperto anche carino
quindi immagino che ora troveremo
charman numero 22 ed ecco alzar mender
guardate che carino numero 23 penultimo
un'altra decorazione per l'albero
che carino e tipo pikachu versione
pupazzo di neve
l'ultimo cappellina pikachu ora vado a
montare l'albero e vi faccio vedere come
di qua con la scritta e l'albero di
natale che carini c'e anche il pupazzo
di neve peter ok ragazzi secondo round
vediamo se riusciamo a trovare il
secondo calendario dell'avvento berlino
che fai
c'è qualcosa di quell'altro calendario
stato facilissimo trovarlo di berlino
berlino mi risveglia sempre quando perdo
ma purtroppo non siamo riusciti a
prendere il secondo calendario abbiamo
perso una vita ora dobbiamo stare molto
attenti che sta facendo berlino
chi è bravo non svegliare i premi ok non
svegliarla è il calendario li devo
riuscire a prenderlo senza svegliarlo ok
mi devi aiutare per lì per fortuna
berlino e facilmente corrompibile con i
pupazzi anche se non posso darglielo
perché lo farebbe in mille pezzi
il calendario dell'avvento dalle mani di
grandi mentre dorme senso svegliarmi mai
silenzio ok mi raccomando
affare fatto bravissimo di un'idea
geniale sostituirò il calendario lamento
che a premi con questa tastiera
speriamo che fate il tifo per me
[Musica]
ci abbiamo fatto per un pelo avete visto
berlino all'improvviso ha provato a
svegliare gremi cioè lui voleva giocare
ma per fortuna sono riuscita a distrarre
i pupazzi meno male
riesco sempre di strada con i pupazzi
sono riusciti a sfilare da graham il
calendario ea mettere la tastiera e li
ha anche provato a suonarla seconda un
boxing questo il calendario dell'avvento
bic quindi ci saranno un sacco di penne
pennarelli pastelli che io adoro vediamo
e lì siamo con numero uno al numero 1
abbiamo la classica quattro colori
numero due un pennarello indelebile
argento proviamolo qua 3 numero 3 una
matita numero 4 con light peak numero 5
numero 5 sono dei vari foglietti da
colorare quindi vari disegni da colorare
un blocchetto numero 6 un'altra quattro
colori ma questa con colori particolari
perché c'è rosa viola verde e celeste
numero 7 un altro pennarello indelebile
ma questo è dorato numero 8 un'altra
matita un po più spesso è un po più
scura un pennarello rosso ed è tutto
decorato con le stelline qua numero 10
un altro pennarello viola numero 11 in
pastello marrone numero 12 pennarello
celeste numero 13 stello giallo 14 una
matita big viola
quindi pastello griso un po argentato
redici una gomma b17 telo rosa pastello
rosso 19 pennarello blu pennarello
bianco a una penna bic ce le 22 un
evidenziatore rosa wow penultimo 23
pastello blu
l'ultima casellina ci sono degli adesivi
di natale ok ragazzi ora dobbiamo
trovare l'ultimo calendario sente un
rumore strano che viene dal corridoio di
l'anno sentite se crimi c'è anche il
calendario quindi dobbiamo andare in più
non trovo berlino berlino ma ecco amy
che succede che c'è nel riina è andato
qua e colmando la vedete
andiamo a prenderlo credo questo scempio
cremi tutta più l'anno volete macrino
per le band o non si è accorta subito
forse meglio girare la palla in testa
vediamo se ci riesco
[Musica]
il calendario browser lì dove ce
l'abbiamo un fatto abbiamo preso
l'ultimo calendario dell'avvento questa
di harry potter ultimo unboxing
purtroppo perché è stato super
divertente questo è un calendario
dell'avvento di harry potter io sono una
grandissima fan di harry potter è questo
che liberi delle vette un po particolari
perché a lui non è piatto come gli altri
ma iniziamo subito l'unboxing dalla
prima casellina se la trovo sarà un po
difficile trovare tutte le caselline
luca la prima casellina vediamo in una
toppa adesiva di stoffa che si può
appunto applicare ai vestiti che bel
numero due al numero 2 abbiamo il
portachiavi della piattaforma 934 numero
tre al numero 3 un ciondolino di
hermione numero 4 è qualcosa di molto
grande la lettera l'aspetto da
tantissimi anni la lettera di ammissione
all ue ma hanno purtroppo non è la
lettera di ammissione però sono vari
buste lettera con lo stemma dico wax
quindi se si vuole appunto mandare una
lettera molto particolare e originale
devo dire molto molto carino e numero 5
che l'ict abbiamo qua ci sarà una
bacchetta da anonime no è una penna di
la bacchetta e alla luce viola quindi
sicuramente e di quella tenne in cui
puoi scrivere i messaggi segreti si
proviamo subito vediamo qua ho fatto un
cuoricino ed ex numero 6
wow questa è la bacchetta di hermione
fellini
vittima è una tenda almeno penso che
questa sia la bacchetta di hermione voi
vi ricordate allora ho sbagliato aperto
il 9 invece del 6 perché ce l'avevo al
contrario in realtà il 6 e 4 sono delle
pergamene appunto per fare i compiti
delle pergamene con lo stemma di
hogwarts quindi si possono usare queste
poi mettere nelle lettere con lo stemma
numero 7
sembra una catenina forse per mettere
poi il ciondolo che abbiamo trovato di
hermione è un bracciale in cui poi si
possono mettere i vari ciondoli che
forse ne troveremo anche altre numero 8
al numero 8 abbiamo dell'inchiostro e
direi che si manca solo la penna con la
piuma forse lo troveremo vediamo il
numero 9 lo abbiamo già aperto prima
quindi passiamo al 10 numero dieci
abbiamo un elastico di grifondoro con il
fiocchetto carinissimo numero 11 al
numero 11 abbiamo un timbro con l'acca
di hogwarts e l'inchiostro qua numero 12
vari ad easyvista un pino numero 13 al
numero 13 abbiamo qualcosa di crif on
d'oro che carini un paio di calzini
rossi e gialli con scritto o con il
colore di grifondoro che bel numero 14
dissentiamo un elastico per capelli
rosso e giallo appunto con il tema
grifondoro che carino numero 15 al
numero quindi se abbiamo una spilla con
il simbolo dei doni della morte numero
16 al numero 16 abbiamo dei lazzi per
scarpe con il simbolo hpt harry potter
anche se questo non si vede
numero 17 17 abbiamo il ciondolo di rom
numero 18
altri calzini che carini questi sono
neri e rossi con le saette e gli
occhiali harry potter che cari numero 19
e gigante vediamo che cos'è il
cerchietto rosso e giallo come appunto
la casata grifondoro e il tema o corse
bellissimo questo cerchietto numero 20
abbiamo un bracciale in cui c'è scritto
ai soleminis werder ai map qua ho
aggiunto io that ma non l'hanno messo
questa è la frase aprire la mappa del
malandrino che in italiano mi sembra che
fosse giuro solennemente di non avere
buone intenzioni che numero 21 siamo
vicini alla fine purtroppo al 21 abbiamo
il ciondolo di harry potter numero 22
ecco qua la penna da usare poi con
l'inchiostro e con cui scrivere le
lettere con il marchio hogwarts guardate
che bella
mi sentivo da per hogwarts secondo
scriverò con questo numero 23 per un
ultimo purtroppo perché mi stavo
divertendo troppo sono troppo pelle
queste sorprese al numero 23 ci sono
questi che non sono sicure se sono
adesivi o tatuaggi penso che siano
tatuaggi
siamo arrivati all'ultimo purtroppo un
po volevo continuare ad aprire sorpreso
e vediamo cosa nell'ultimo ed ecco
all'ultimo è ovviamente la bacchetta di
harry queste sono sicura che la
bacchetta di harry perché mi ricordo
benissimo appunto il design
vediamo se anche questa è una pen si
riprenda anche questo è bellissima qual
è l'oggetto vi è piaciuto di più di
questo calendario abbiamo vinto la
challenge scrivetemi i miei commenti
qual è stato il vostro calendario
dell'avvento preferito tra quelli che
abbiamo aperto il mio quello di harry
potter mi è piaciuto tantissimo ma anche
quello di pokémon anche da altre rabello
però quello di harry potter mi è
piaciuto tantissimo
come potete vedere e scrivete anche il
vostro oggetto preferito di ogni
calendario zoom nei con me lasciate un
bel mi piace ora vi lascio 4 caselline
su cui cliccare per vedere i miei altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite e
buona visione